taken for granted that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
when addressing black voters on the
campaign Trail president Trump regularly
raised a provocative question
we can never fix our problems by relying
on the same politicians who created our
problems in the first place
look how much
African-American communities have
suffered under Democratic control
to those I say the following
what do you have to lose
well it turns out minorities are losing
a lot and Joe Biden's America they've
gotten poorer as their streets have
gotten more dangerous
especially in urban areas and it's
tragic regular everyday people need to
be safe if they're harassing people who
are vulnerable and nobody gets involved
uh it could create a dangerous situation
I almost got attacked by a homeless man
a couple of days ago I do worry about
the crime and the homelessness and
people being pushed on the subway it's
really dangerous now this is all
happening courtesy of democrat rule
especially in urban areas well tonight
from New York a Bastion of liberalism we
see the Democrats firewall of support
beginning to crack now how couldn't it
not
every sane person out there sees the
perverse incentives that are created
when Subway Subway Heroes like Daniel
Penny are cuffed and charged while
deranged psychos are free to terrorize
an attack
that's what happened to Elizabeth Gomes
I don't even feel like I'm the same
person that I was seven months ago after
that attack he just wanted to damage me
because he damaged me he damaged my life
I would never be the same again I'm not
that person that I was seven months ago
and if I had somebody like Penny around
maybe things would have been different I
probably wouldn't have suffered so much
pain and suffering and these things that
I go through
yeah she lost one of her eyes
so many hard-working minorities have
been victims of hideous assaults
assaults committed by career criminals
by the way career criminals who Alvin
Bragg treat as though they were the real
victims forget the hard-working people
because in his mind the streets the
Subways the buses they belong to the
criminals
if you use any of them you're taking
your life into your own hands frankly
it's your fault and if you fight back oh
boy you'll probably be the one who gets
thrown in jail
that poor Bodega clerk Jose Alba who
fought back last July against a thug who
would have robbed and brutalized him he
narrowly escaped the same fate as Daniel
penny
think about it all that guy wanted to do
and make a decent living support his
family and come home alive at the end of
the day
but there was even a five minute long
debate about whether he should have been
charged is obscene
now thankfully New Yorkers who've been
living in this crime spree were up in
arms and rallied to support Mr Alba
causing Alvin Bragg to drop the murder
charges against him
the signs of discontent among minority
voters aren't limited to Crime look what
happened after residents discovered
illegals were being housed in school
gymnasiums reports that as many as 20
gyms were going to be used for this
purpose
[Music]
now scenes like this sent City officials
scrambling for some type of cover story
we have exhausted options for
traditional shelter sites for the
migrants we are now turning to Temporary
alternative options like gyms and large
open spaces for some relief we always
set up uh the school gyms as an
emergency respite the word respite means
short term and it means for a place to
go to get yourself settled how
condescending thank you we know what
respite means sweetheart none of this is
credible No One Believes what she's
saying everybody knows that Democrats
support liberal immigration policies and
that they like open borders because they
want votes and their donors want cheap
labor
the only Force capable of closing the
floodgates is an angry and frankly
energized American electorate
and more blacks and Latinos are
beginning to see just how much they had
to lose by sticking with the Democrats
and of course their destructive policies
now look no further than what's going on
in another left-wing Paradise Chicago
they value fraudulent Asylum Seekers
over their everyday residents while this
crisis May constitute an emergency for
the city of Chicago it does not
constitute an emergency for the South
Shore Community
what's important is that we really
establish that this is a humanitarian
crisis and we're here
you're not supposed to interrupt you're
not supposed to Center
I think it would be very fair for every
homeless immigrant that you bring in
that you scoop up one of the homeless
individuals in our community
I think that would be fair
well you notice there's suddenly an
explosion of nimbyism as in not in my
backyard please
these people are torque for good reason
they're feeling the consequences of
failed liberal policies firsthand
of course I made a huge mistake in
electing their brand new mayor Brandon
Johnson who could actually if it's
possible be worse than Lori Lightfoot
at his inauguration speech he compared
the death of Adam Toledo who was killed
after shooting a gun at passing cars
to the death of an off-duty police
officer named Ariana Preston
you know the tears of Adam Toledo
his parents
tears of Adam Toledo's parents
are made of the same sorrow
as the parents of officer
Preston's parents that's a wonder they
have any police officers left in Chicago
he by the way had the nerve to then show
up at officer Preston's Funeral
a complete fraud
but so is the entire Democrat
establishment at this point people like
Eric Adams Lightfoot they complain about
migrants only when the migrants arrive
in their cities again it's not in my
backyardism
but if they really cared they'd be
burning up the White House switchboards
not trying to pass the buck to
Republicans
third meantime their constituents are
left twisting in the Wind
they're vulnerable they're scared and
now
some are Furious
this all gives Republicans a huge
opening
now although historically Republicans
have struggled with minority voters this
was in large part due to the fact that
before Trump most Republicans didn't
even try to reach out to Black and
Latino voters that was a big mistake
but Trump's Outreach efforts were far
better and he did improve his support
among black men and among Latinos
that's why the Democrats are so
frequently hurling these charges of
racism against conservatives and against
institutions that value objective Merit
as the angle pointed out last night
their transparent goal at this point is
to keep minorities compliant and
frightened
frightened that white supremacists are a
bigger threat to their future and their
families than a dismal economy an open
border and skyrocketing crime
look this is a lame argument and if
conservatives bother to show up bother
to make their case bother to stand with
the people who are being brutalized they
may just find willing converts who say
to themselves at this point with things
this bad what do I have to lose and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else